the question says they say this so I
think to learn how to add to this you
have to remember what what index
notation what these powers actually mean
so example just with like normal numbers
if I wrote two to the power of four okay
what's that she short for like what do I
mean when I say it's it's two times two
times two
right having a power is a short form of
modification if you want to multiply two
numbers together okay so they're more
generally speaking if I had say oh I
don't know P to the power of four right
so some prettier I don't know what it is
but it still follows exactly the same
rules right it will be P 19 times three
times P okay good now have a look at
this what you've got inside deep huge
right we could have said P was d cubed
right so if I just took this live right
and instead of P I wrote that okay see
what I've done raised had to the power
of four exactly the same thing except
I'm just swapping topping out substitute
if you like this is going to be well
what did I do the previous line I had to
beat P times P times P but this time
I've got DQ 2 everywhere I see P I'm
gonna put a DQ like this D cubed times D
cubed four times just like you had in
this life right you see what I've done
so just everywhere I had a pain there
I've written D cube and I had to write
it four times
okay but you guys all know what just one
of these means right one of these here
just on its own that's just D times D
times D but I have to do that four times
right so let's not equal to I could
write it all out if I wanted
that'd be D times D times D is the first
one times D times T times D there's the
second one
maybe I'll just sort of put a bracket
underneath it to show right then another
one make sure I don't lose count you now
when you count them up I count 12 T's
right
due to the power 12 okay now that's
correct but that was a very long way to
go about it right you can say that what
this tells you is one of the index laws
they believe that when you raise a power
to a power right you're multiplying
these indices okay
so really that's the same as oh I could
have done this three times four that's
how I would get rid of the brackets okay
so remembering that law obviously it
enables you to do it much quicker but
this is why that war is true okay
because I don't just want you to set
them because someone tells you to yeah
yeah all right now I think let's let me
write the question first
okay I think understanding index laws
again is the cave right now just to help
us out a little bit instead of writing
this is a division thing I'm gonna write
it as a fraction you guys know a
division in fractions same deal just a
different way of writing it right so I'm
going to write this Q power of 8 on Q
cubed that's confusing okay
now I've just done that to make it a bit
simpler what I'm about to do I'm going
to write these out just like I wrote
these out okay I should have ate Q's on
the top and three on the bottom one two
three four five six seven
yes good they go there's the numerator
and the denominator has three now I'm
just going to treat this like I usually
treat fractions right I could cancel
some things out can I find a few things
I can cancel work you up here that means
one debit it's just my y know here yeah
I'm going to show that so I canceled
three queues for the top and bottom what
that leads me is 1 2 2 4 5 queues so
that's 5 now just like before right what
would be a quicker way than writing it
all out writing all that the index law
that corresponds to this is it's about
subtraction minus 3 that's why the 5
came from right so that's kind of a
shorthand if you remember that division
here will do this you can go straight to
^ 5 yeah okay so that would be incorrect
and I mean if you have a look at the way
I've long hand written it now you can
see why like there are no negatives in
here at all a bit like when I wrote out
this and this and I just expanded it I
don't have any minus signs right so
there shouldn't be any of my final
answer either anyone ask me another
question
okay sure
okay sure right sorry this is what the
question says okay how do I explain this
remember just a general problem solving
strategy right that will help you a lot
right is when you look at a question you
don't know how to do it try and simplify
it in times of a question that you do
know how to solve okay so I'm gonna put
some numbers on it just like I put
numbers on up here I've got the reason
why this is different to this is because
I have a in here I have a product I'm
multiplying two things together that's
the only difference between these two
questions okay so if I can work out what
to do with a product when I raise a
product to a power I could work out the
whole thing so example let's do 2 times
3 right there's a product that I know
okay and let's raise that to the power
of 3 okay so this would be quite a large
number right now what's that equal to I
can approach this two different ways
khana I can say 2 times 3 that's 6 to
the power of 3 right now 6 squared is 36
so I think that's 216 from memory
someone can check it on the calculator
okay now there's another way to think
about this and again it's going to go
back to writing the whole thing out so
you can see the pattern 2 times 3 cubed
what does it mean what does cubed mean
it means do it three times right now let
me see if I can do that without making
it 6 it's gonna be 2 times 3 times 2
times 3 times 2 times 3 one more time is
that okay
see what I've done I've just gone from
this to this
without simplifying the 2 times 3 but I
can rearrange this stuff right I can
match up the twos and I can match up the
3 I can say that's 2 times 2 times 2
that's how many I count yeah and 3 times
3 times 3 you see that
so now going down back into index form
that's two cubed and that's three cubed
okay now see what's happened right let's
compare this line and this line if
you've got two things that are
multiplying and then you put power on
them okay that's just the same as
putting the power on each number
individually you see that
so that twos just become that to his
three has just become yeah right so
let's have a look at this the product is
made up of a five and an R to the power
of six so I'm going to follow this
pattern here I'm going to take each one
individually 5 + R to the power 6 and
I'm gonna rage raise each of those to
the power of whatever
what is it - you know so I raise this
one to the power of 2 and I'll raise
this one to the power - okay so now this
problem is just like the one I did
before isn't it five squared you know
five it is five and here I'm going to
multiply the indices together it just so
happens that it ends up being the same
number that I got before six times two
is twelve okay so there you go that's
what five out of six or squared that's
what equals 2 because this is the this
is the wall that goes with it you can
break apart two factors